I've always given him a hard time
because
it's very easy to uh
and then yeah when social media came to
be he continued to be his his uh you
know ridiculous self and uh
he you make it so so easy like you post
these layups where it's like a shirtless
selfie in front of his Emmy nominations
and I'm like why'd you frame it like
that man like why is that because that's
the wall in the gym no there's four
walls that's not the world
that is such BS I know that's not true I
know that's not true and you do post a
lot of thirst straps for a 59 year old
man I don't even thirst trap is that's
that's impossible uh you we we know the
thirst traps it's true yeah Shadow and
you couldn't be more right I mean let's
just show one you know just but yep
there we go okay but you're in it